aber ich wollte mal sehr gut in der
schule ich hatte erst 25 25 lustig was
genau bereits willkommen beim neuen
video und zwar habe ich mir für heute
mal so ein thema überlegt das bestimmt
jeder von euch also das spricht auf
jeden fall jeden von euch an und ich
wette ihr könnt euch mit 1 punkten
super identifizieren wie im titel ja
bestimmt schon gelesen ab geht's heute
um dinge die jugendliche heimlich machen
also ich meine jetzt nicht unbedingt
dinge die man jetzt noch heimlich macht
so so ich jetzt mit 17 sondern die man
so heimlich gemacht hat mit 14 zum teil
natürlich auch noch mit 17 aber ich will
gar nicht lange lagern ich würde sagen
wir fangen einfach mal und ich möchte
ganz viel spaß bei rickfelder ist auf
jeden fall noch nach oben da und ich
sollte nicht so lange erzählen
der erste punkt ist wirklich sehr sehr
ich will es nicht sagen gut aber noch
also schon manchmal gut auf jeden fall
kennt ist wie oft soll ich eigentlich
sagen können ja schon alle ihr kennt das
er alle und zwar kennt ihr das ja
bestimmt wenn ihr euch so denkbar ich
habe morgen in den ersten beiden schon
so kein bock auf das und das fach und
eigentlich muss ich auch gar nicht
hingehen nur wie soll ich das jetzt
meine eltern erzählen ganz einfach so
scheiße morgen im ersten beiden doppel
schon englisch momenten habe ich doch
schon öfter papa ja mein sohn ich wollte
dir nur sagen also ich habe morgen in
den ersten mal irgendwie doch kein
englisch weil der ist krank der lehrer
und du musst dich dann halt erst um halb
zehn
also ich kann auch länger schlafen
moment mal aber das war doch der lehrer
der letzte woche auch schon krank war
und wenn mich nicht alles täuscht davor
die woche auch ja der ist halt irgendwie
öfter krank solche lehrer gibt es halt
der kerbs gut also wenn ich mich an
meine schullaufbahn innere saß um punkt
acht uhr auf dem platz sondern würde ich
sagen wir sind auch schon bei punkt 2
und zwar dass wenn meine schule richtig
scheiße klausur wieder bekommt also ich
meine ist so wichtig richtig scheiße für
euch ausgefallen vier - oder fünf plus
und dann kriegt man die am besten in der
ersten stunde oder so wieder und braucht
man halt auch
muss noch diese sechs stunden überstehen
müssen wir das bei seinen eltern
enthalten kann und dann immer dieses
gefühl was man dabei hat und ja aber man
konnte das ja auch umgehen ich meine ich
wollte keine unterschrift mehr aber man
konnte ist umgehen ich habe es aber
ehrlich ich hab es nie gemacht aber es
gibt sehr viele die es gemacht haben
aber ich hoffe mal sehr gut in der
schule ich hatte f 252 5 + habe ich
schon wieder ne 5 und einfach immer
diese lehrer die nur unterschrift haben
wollen nach richtig warm als auch keinen
fall erfahren
ok unterschrift fälschen übungsmodus
sowie wie machen dass der max nur noch
mal so zeigt oder zack ja das wäre jetzt
muss ich das aber irgendwie auch drauf
haben so scheiße fällt das auch nicht
auf wenn so leute kommen wir zu punkt 3
und zwar weiß jetzt nicht mehr von euch
nun den schwestern schwester ich weiß
nicht welches schwester oder einen
bruder hat oder wer als einzelkind ist
aber manchmal kann man halt so sagen ach
scheiße ich habe noch zwei euro ich
brauche aber zehn euro und dann sucht
man halt nach gilt da ich weiß dass wenn
du das video wahrscheinlich sehen wie
ich hab sogar mit ihm gedreht also auf
jeden fall weiß ich ich habe ihm ab und
zu schon mal geld abgezogen er mir aber
auch
warum mache ich jetzt so keine ahnung
oder man schaut halt geld den eltern
aber das ist nicht so schön hat aber die
geschwister ist okay könnt ihr machen
kein ding ja und was anhalt passiert ist
sehr oft so aus
wo ist mein zehn euro schein
ja ich weiß
was machst du da nix ja heute so viel
dazu ich hoffe natürlich das video hat
euch gefallen hatte spaß beim ansehen
dank auch an meinen bruder der mir halt
so ein bisschen geholfen hat der hat ja
sogar auch mitgespielt und als
dankeschön gleich mal ihr könnt ja mal
sein instagram abhängig fahrzeugen die
beschreibung wenn ihr bock ab und
ansonsten würde ich sagen aber nie
vergessen auch nichts zu verpassen
daumen nach oben wir hammer und verpasst
auf keinen fall am mittwoch kommt um 15
und video
das ist humor haben um das halt es wird
auf jeden fall lustig ist ich war
gestern in köln
es war einfach richtig geil und auf
jeden fall würde ich sagen mir auf der
linken seite geht weiter mit meinem
letzten video das war dinge wie sie
mädchen und jungs machen der dritte teil
und hier auf der anderen seite mit dem
netz video mit von von wein und mir war
ich mal
und ja auf jeden fall mittwoch ein
einschalten nicht verpassen
drei leute